uh let's think back to tuesday's lesson
the whole idea
of locus was enabling us to graph on the
complex plane we've been graphing in the
cartesian plane
for years and we've been graphing shapes
that we've
thought of in terms of like you know y
equals x squared i know exactly what
shape that is
it's a it's a y equals x squared team
come on
that's a parabola thank you okay
parabola it's there y equals 1
over x that's a hyperbola
y equals 2x minus 5. that's a
straight line gradient y intercept
you're all fine with that right
and we wanted to expand this idea using
our
complex number notation right but mostly
on tuesday
we stayed in the part of the pun the
domain of things that you're pretty
comfortable already graphing with
right straight lines uh regions bounded
by
straight lines so we did some shading
and stuff like that um circles
and things within circles or things
outside of circles right so that's where
we went
we want to go into slightly less
familiar territory
um today and then we're gonna go into
really weird wacko territory
next week okay so um if you haven't
already please go ahead and um
plot these on four separate argon
diagrams
but the first one is going to help us to
graph the locus of
uh make sure i get this right z minus i
equals z
last one okay
so what is this thing now before we get
started i'm just going to put right out
there i know
several of you will have perhaps
encountered some of these equations
before
and much like how i described oh y
equals x squared bam a shape appears in
your mind
maybe you look at this and a shape
immediately appears in your mind and if
that's you
then great however i'm going to just
emphasize the fact that what i don't
want like i don't
like it would be great if once i give
you the four equations for this you get
to a point of what we call fluency
where you look at it and you're like i'm
immediately familiar with that
that'll be nice okay um it'll mean you
can graph these faster
but graphing these faster is not the
real thing that i'm after i want you to
be able to look at these things
and think through them very carefully
okay that's the main goal
um because you're gonna get things that
are unfamiliar and i don't want you to
get to that point say oh no
this is not in the list of 17 equations
that i've i know what the form is right
i want you to be able to reason through
what's going on so
when you have a look at this particular
example you can see it's paired with the
first
pair of points that i've asked you to
write there and that's because
the way you could rewrite this in a more
helpful way is to say
this is a distance from
some complex number z this is the idea
of locus it can move around in different
places
so long as its distance from
this point is equal to
its distance from
this point does that make sense so this
is a point of comparison
right um to think back to like this is
why we use the absolute value notation
for the modulus if you were to think
back to something like say
the absolute value of 3 take away 5. i
know you can just do that numerically
you can just say that's negative 2 take
the positive you get an answer
right but the geometric meaning of this
is
what's the distance from three to five
that's what that means
okay and that's that's why by the way
the distance from three to five
is the same as the distance from five to
three like numerically that's the same
but that's because
the geometric meaning underneath it is
no matter which direction
you're looking at it's the same okay so
on your argon diagram now
having plotted these two points i want
us to think about
where might zed be able to roam we think
about zed as like being able to move
about the complex plane
here's our imaginary axis here's our
real axis
and you should have by this point i and
i'm gonna eyeball there negative one
okay so have a think about how you would
verbally describe and that verbal
description is actually really important
how would you verbally describe the
places that z could go
such that if you measured your distance
to i
and said oh it's like four units and
then you measured your
distance to negative one they should be
the same
can anyone verbally describe me and
that's tricky because you're you'd
rather just like point
or like look on your page and draw
something could you tell me a spot
on the graph that would satisfy that
equation
what do you reckon between those two
half way
i i like both those answers i just think
the first one was easier
halfway between these two points
if i put you know and i'd love you to
plot this on there now if i took the
midpoint
of that interval right so i'm going to
place that in fact i'll even draw the
interval i've got it in there
and if you put that midpoint there right
by the way
what is that midpoint you actually know
the coordinates of that point
have a think in complex number terms
horizontally it's halfway between zero
and
negative one so i would say that its
real component would be negative
say liam huh thank you you had it yeah
like i heard i
i saw you say and then what about its
imaginary component i'll give you a clue
it's a plus it's it's half of i
isn't it because i'm gonna go halfway up
that's the way the midpoint formula
works
so you're like oh okay there's one spot
that works but this is
not the only one can someone again
verbally give me another one again
zero the origin
this works doesn't it in fact if you've
got another color there
you can see um when i take my distance
to i
uh it's got to be one unit and when i
take my distance to
negative one of course that also has to
be one unit so that's that's also great
um you can now see there's symmetry in
this situation right
even though i don't have much
information here a coordinate that's on
the other side but equivalent to
the origin would be uh with this
spot here wouldn't it like it's the same
distance of one
here and the same distance of one here
do you agree with that okay
so all of these spots these um x's that
i'm plotting they all
meet this condition the distance the
modulus is the same does this make sense
you're starting to get an idea right you
can start to put a few more on here i
could wrong color
i could keep on going off in this
direction i could keep on going
that direction we are going to create
what kind of shape this is going to be
generally speaking it's a straight line
but particularly it's a straight line
that
i'll do my best to thread the needle
it's a straight line that takes that
interval that we drew dotted earlier on
right takes that interval
and does kind of two things to it right
um it slices it
in half because that's kind of the
definition right those two parts have to
be the same
that's what we get from this equation
but it doesn't just slice it in half it
slices it in half
at a particular angle what is this angle
you can see
this is 90 degrees it's a perpendicular
bisector right so in fact that's so
important to um
note i'm just going to jot that down
this is the perpendicular
bisector
now because it is the perpendicular
bisector good morning
and because i started off with a
particularly easy
set of points you might be able to look
at this and actually just state
a cartesian equation something in terms
of just wires and x's
that describes this straight line i'll
give you a clue you could start it off
with y equals how would you describe
this thing
uh what's what can you tell me about
like this is a straight line right so
you need
a gradient and a y-intercept that'll
give you the form so what's the gradient
it's negative 1 it's decreasing clearly
and so i'm going to write
minus 1 there we know it's 1 minus 1 by
the way because that gradient's 1
and perpendicular has to multiply to
negative 1 negative reciprocal so that's
great
what's my y intercept well zero so plus
zero
i'm fine that's that's it okay